la shadoks caravelle fondé l'espace et
la terre peu à peu disparaissant au bout
de cinq à six semaines on a perçu par le
travers grave qui dérive
c'était la lune avec les trois
malheureux shadoks abandonné qui
pleurait comme des madeleines les pour
le jour après c'était le cosmo autobus
et les shadoks à grosse tête ont repêché
et puis après devinez qui et oui les jbe
ils étaient tombés en panne deux aussi
mais comme le bar achats d'or qui
n'avaient pas de rancune et que de toute
façon il avait oublié il et son valet
jbe aussi par dessus le marché
et comme toutes ces aventures l'année
avait pas mal fatigué ils décidèrent les
uns et les autres qu'ils iraient en
vacances se repose
le marin dit qu'il connaissait justement
une planète exprès pour ça où il faisait
toujours bon et toujours chaud
c'est ainsi que les shadoks et l'egypte
un jour il ya très très longtemps
prirent le chemin de la planète vacances
et mire le cap sur le solaire
et le marin qui les avait tous sauvés
terminal histoire sur une de ces
vieilles maxime dont il avait le secret
c'est encore dans la marine qu'il y a le
plus de na